okay here's something crazy the US Navy
relies on submarines submarines carry
nuclear weapons and a bunch of other
weapons they carry hundreds of sailors
and they can kind of be invisible
submarines are crazy and we made a whole
video about it but anyway the US is
giving the plans and the specs of their
most valuable weapon to Australia
they've done this once before with the
UK but since then this has never
happened and it's because Australia is
over here in the Pacific this place that
the US is more and more worried about
because of a rising China and the US is
scared and so they're giving their
submarine technology to Australia and
teaming up with them and doing joint
exercises and riding alongside
Australians and Americans all in the
same submarine and it's this whole thing
to make U.S power projected into the
Pacific so that China feels scared but
what it might do is maybe make it less
likely that China will invade Taiwan or
maybe it will provoke it